[Music]
I mean you know my show just got
cancelled and there's a there's like
sort of a wonderfulness there's
obviously some other feelings for sure
but like there's like this opening my
goes very excited to get in touch with
you and yeah other people that I was
like not just podcasts and self-serving
promotion stuff although I'm happy to
see you obviously but um just meals
phone calls getting back to your life
yeah
just well sitting with my wife and
having no other program running I'm a
very present you know this is kind of a
brag but I'm very present with my wife
and very loving so she's not I think if
she was here she would tell you that I'm
not like hold on we're gonna write that
down constantly person but like now that
the show has concluded mm-hmm I just
feel I feel I keep saying I feel like
the sky in Montana I'm just like wide
open so I'm like reading so much
I told you I came here this is all I'm
doing today yeah it's nice how my life
was much longer than it was a show
producer you know what I mean yeah that
was four years well last night was the
the season finale and also the series
finale so you know here we are the
morning after I would imagine you know
there's a bit of a hangover with that
you must have conflicting emotions well
the whole thing I didn't I didn't expect
that you're not a flat earther what a
disappointment I'm just kidding yeah I
was noticing on the way in that I like I
felt sky Montana and joy and like really
joy and gratitude that's not I always
have to tell people that I'm not like
repressing anything I'm a very
emotionally available person so if I was
devastated or angry I would tell you but
I do sort of psychically feel a little
bit of the sadness because we watched it
together I would imagine as a group oh
the whole cast and crew or yeah pretty
much I mean everybody that could come so
we watched it last night and that made
it more sad my brain is very forward
moving I'm very fortunate and the times
of my life that like things I've been
privileged to have other things
cancelled you know what I mean and I
tend to
it's like I'm getting pushed instead of
I'm getting snowed under I feel like I'm
getting pushed you know what I mean it's
mobilizing right so I kind of like that
energy there's like a Sharky and like a
friendly shark though that likes to keep
moving and I sort of thrive with
uncertainty and I enjoy pressure and and
I like novelty so there are all these
good feelings but then you watch it and
every shot of a TV show that you make is
a memory of course it's not I'm you
should I wish you I wish I had invited
you but I sometimes feel like then what
do you know anyone succumb to those I
would it totally combat sorry I don't
like I just feel like thrill I feel like
I'm inviting some people to something
that like they feel bad if they can't
come you know I mean it's almost like
this New England polity that I'm like I
don't want to bother somebody make you
come to Beverly Hills on a Sunday night
oh my god it would have been cool
I agree well we watched it and and and
if you had sat next to me what I was
saying to Val was like there's a scene
with John John Mulaney and I and he's
it's so funny he kills it and he sort of
explaining that he's not a jerk he's
sort of coaching me to tell people that
he's not a jerk and I go to Val I'm like
it's 5:00 in the morning or like 4:30 in
the morning when we're shooting this Wow
and I'm losing my mind and in the scene
like you know I look normal I look like
yeah it looked like it's 7 o'clock and
yeah it looks like it's in real time
yeah exactly super composed but that's
what you don't that's what I didn't
really know is when you're watching a
movie now when I watch anything I have a
pretty good nose for like I bet that's
the first thing they shot you know
because it's not the first yeah you
don't start with the first scene and so
that takes you out oh that's being
present for the experience of what the
artist is trying to convey sometimes you
know it can be I have to like sort of
make an effort to turn that part off but
I can but sometimes I like to do it
especially if it's something that I
don't care about if it's a movie that
I'm not really like waiting to be swept
away by I can kind of go like isn't it
weird to think that that's Tuesday and
when the person walks out of the
building that's Thursday you know right
right an exterior and the interior was a
set and the exterior is a real location
so they probably flew somewhere for that
shot you know there's movies like that
where they they say like the David Lynch
movie Eraserhead
uh-huh there's a shot where he walks out
of the building and the
people who know that movie really well
are like the next shot is three years
later cuz they like reenact finding her
there's some story and I love I kind of
like stuff like that
well Mulaney was great yeah I was a jerk
and then the fact that you then get up
on stage and kill it and and own him for
that
ya know is that's comedy well I did what
I Cana ste yeah you know that's that's
really I I sort of think about what
really kind of gets me going isn't
necessarily comedy it's it's the
perspective of a comedian which is very
honest and usually going wherever the
line is and I don't just mean in terms
of offensive things I just mean the line
in terms of thinking or usually people
stop and stop saying what they're
thinking
comedians usually start at the line and
move forward whereas most people who
take the line as a cue to stop so
honesty really excites me yeah and then
to see him respect you for that yeah and
not hold a grudge yeah or be irritated
but instead kind of embrace you and
welcome you into his fold
an old programming Pete like Christian
Pete thinks it's impolite and apologizes
to him right when really he's sort of
learning that lesson that like no that's
what we do we take unpleasant emotions I
said on another podcast I was like life
is falling down and getting up and
talking about it that's what we're all
doing mm-hmm and the artists job
whatever you're doing you could be an
artist as a mother it doesn't matter it
doesn't have to be like a professional
artist but the art of life is to share
and talk about it I was talking to
somebody like the first painting the
first time somebody painted something if
you've ever taken psychedelics is you're
like you get overwhelmed with a feeling
of like oh I'm sort of alone in here you
sort of feel trapped sometimes like in
your body and I feel like arts job if
somebody paints this and goes this is
how I feel sometimes this right here is
how I feel and other people look at and
they go I get that and and it's
wonderful it's warm all of a sudden it's
less isolated and scary yeah because the
truth is undeniable yeah even if it's
only your personal truth and you're
unsure as to whether anybody else is
gonna be able to connect with that yeah
it doesn't matter well the more specific
we were and the more specific I've been
in everything that I've done my podcasts
and my book and the show and even silly
sketches the more specific we got the
more universal they became yeah that's
an interesting thing where you think
like oh it's gonna
so inside baseball they're gonna lose
people but that's actually I love you
Rory I've never done a setup
you know them saying it's not about that
like it's such a weird thing that we
live in this world of living metaphor
Bhagwan das but Bhagavad dossier is
named different than I do I'm lazy sa
Bhagwan I probably the proper no I don't
think it is I think it's foggy fog of on
but I'm lazy see I won't even my tongue
my tongue doesn't even do sit-ups
Bhagwan das I'm now there's nothing to
do with Boston I know I'm just lazy
Bhagwan dot says life is a metaphor and
I think there's something interesting
like your story the feeling of like your
body or container being a metaphor for
your inner world is interesting and
that's why your story of being winded
going up the stairs we all know
exasperation whether it's physical or
emotional or mental or psychic or
whatever it might be so we love these so
people telling a story about stand-up
who cares I had people come up to me a
lot of musicians that related to the
show photographers artists academics
that were just like yeah that's what it
feels like to pursue a dream whether or
not you're resistant like rolling a huge
tire like what you do or getting up on
stage and bombing but you know like peed
in the first season I told everybody I
was a little bit eerie how well this
series wraps up yeah and that's true if
you look at the first if you look at the
pilot first episode of the first season
Pete goes up on stage and is unable to
take his pain and sort of alchemy is it
into comedy in real time which is
exactly what he does in the series
finale is something happens to him now
that that's to me is is a big spiritual
practice is like we can all look back on
our things and go you know now that I've
had some perspective in some therapy
that bad thing really was the best thing
that could have happened to me but the
trick is to do those things in real time
so while you're suffering can you be
present not later can you go like oh the
universe knew what it was doing can you
say thank you to suffering while it's
happening that's the game so you see
that in the macrocosm of Pete suffering
and then going onstage and doing it in
real time
yeah learning that it's okay even in
front of John especially in front of
John to say I don't think he was a dick
but he was kind of a dick and and and to
have that rewarded is is a big metaphor
it's so like it's a big discovery
for him almost yes and the show ends on
this very hopeful know that these new
doors are opening yeah and it makes me
wonder what season four would have been
yeah like where do you go from there
when it's crashing and it's all about
like you know his struggle and now he's
got this new horizon well after the show
was cancelled I you know I wear the same
pants a lot I'm not really interested in
changing my pants I don't [ __ ] my pants
I change I change you know what I mean
yeah the underwear is the is the
protective barrier that I've got every
day but I don't care about pants and I
don't care about clothes I look at
whatever there's bit milk stains and
stuff from my babies I'm I just don't
care I just don't have one of those
minds that really carries it but I like
dressing up sometimes anyway that's a
digression so there's something about
what was I saying I lost it
uh what were we talking about talking
about clothes pants oh so I I was
wearing the same pants for months the
pants that I wore for my comedy special
dirty clean I was still wearing until
about a week ago uh-huh maybe four days
ago so as I'm changing these disgusting
things I took out in my pocket because
there's all these interesting things in
my pocket there's all these stories and
I found the the season four outline the
breakdown that we had written and I just
saw the first line cuz it was folded in
fourths so I couldn't see the whole
thing and I wasn't really interested in
reading the whole thing I knew it but
the first line was Pete gets a really
big break and I was like well that's
interesting because the show is isn't as
I've joked before it's not called
flourishing it's called crashing and is
about what it's like to be an open-mic
her and it was about what it's like the
origin story told slower
the story of crashing three seasons is
usually a montage you know it's like a
five minute montage in the story of a
comedian or Seinfeld or other shows
about comics they're already just
successful we want to slow that down as
close to real time without being
excruciating so when I looked at Pete
gets a really big break you know and I'm
telling you it's not just revisionist
like I'll just change how I feel I saw
that and I was like that changes the
show a little bit like once he gets a
break now instead of you the viewer
wondering what might happen to Pete
which I really like it keeps the medium
hot you know it's like active in your
imagination we're just telling you oh he
a talk show or something like that which
would have been fun for sure but it
would it might have changed yeah the
whole tenor 10 the balance of it yes
shifts yes
which he gets all a big break that's the
writers line and I was like hmm
are we on taraj now yeah keep concerned
if he can do the movie if he's on the
tour like it's not it's fun so you don't
root for him as much right he yes we
again it would have been fun to do but
there's something about a show that was
just about what's gonna happen which is
the feeling that every comedian can
relate to any creative person going like
trying to make a living at what they
love can relate to the idea of okay he's
in the club so he can go into the arena
now and he's good enough to sort of hold
his own and he's gonna grow and we sort
of see oh he's gonna learn this and this
and this yeah like in the finale he does
stand up expressing anger about his
girlfriend slowing him down when he was
trying to get on the train it's very
basic anger it's pretty benign anger but
at least he's showing an emotion that he
had never shown on stage before he was
usually just like what's the deal with
ice packs which is great but at the end
he's like really sort of you're seeing a
catharsis in him as he rants and and as
being more animated and mobile on stage
I think it's exciting for us to go
hopefully for the fans of the show to
talk about it like what do you think
happens well he's probably in truth
he'll probably grind it out in that Club
for ten years before something big
happens which might not be the most
interesting fourth season if we really
told it as slowly as life happens I mean
everybody knows it takes ten years to
sort of become minted there's there's a
whole nother set of stories that could
be mined and told for sure about what
that life is I mean the the JED in me
and and being in that room and our
ambition with the show of course we we
had a nice season that we wanted to tell
and HPL really liked it that's not why
they cancelled it they numbers were good
they were up from season two all right
you mean the ratings yeah I believe they
were but it also was an expensive show
you know and that's all it comes down to
it I it's like the price of the show and
this is the same thing with my talk show
they look at the price they look at the
numbers and I they very Casey blue
the head of programming really like
passionately and compassionately
explained to me that it was just a
financial this was that like just a
phone call that you get yeah but I
freaked him out like I really weirded
Kasey out I love Casey I loved working
with him and I think Jed told him that I
tend to be talk about dealing with
things in real time can you process
suffering in real time and not forget
that it's just can you be genuinely
grateful yeah and can you remember the
decisions ants and that there's
something really wonderful happening and
there are things out of our control and
can we instead of falling can you kind
of incorporate it into your little dance
and he said you know this sorry to be
self-serving but he was like I've made a
lot of calls like this I'll never forget
this call he's that sweet because you
did three seasons of this show it was
you know wildly embraced yeah you're
beloved as a result of this and you got
to share this story with so many of the
you know notable comics that they all
love right you know it became very
inclusive for unshare mmunity well you
know one of the things of my life I'm
almost I'm turning 40 this month and I'm
really kind of getting a better look at
what I'm but I don't feel old you some
people even like that I'm like that with
Casey's phone call and I'm the same way
with 40 I'm like wow what a privilege
it's so exciting to be 40 I always
wanted to be 40 when I was a kid I
wanted to be in this I've always been 40
I've always been 40 have been a dorky
dad my whole life now I finally have a
kid to be dorky with it's finally be the
person that you've always been I filled
out the suit I've always been wearing it
but it just looks sloppy and stupid on
me and now I'm filling it out and it's a
great feeling but I love honesty and I
love solidarity I love sharing like to
me crashing as a show was about if it
sucks you're doing it right which is
something that I sort of picked up and
heard from other comedians when I was
handing out flyers or when I was bombing
when you hear the stories of like all of
your heroes bill burr told me a story of
leaving a club and hearing someone
saying that redheaded guy sucked and
you're like when you're young and
walking to your car and you hear someone
from the audience and they don't know
you're there and then you hear that bill
burr the [ __ ] greatest and he got
that so like we like to kind of select
all and
that pain and just act not not bill I'm
just saying most of us like to act like
we just sort of showed up complete right
but I love telling anybody that's
pursuing any dream that it's actually
the feedback of it being difficult and
being painful means you belong to a
lineage now you belong to our species
it's almost like an induction we took
you as a young boy into the Serengeti to
hunt and it was terrible and you were
scared or all these weird you know
rituals that we used to do where you
have to go in some terrible cave and
it's designed to scare you that mints
you and and sort of gives you that blood
bond to being a comedian we haven't
really spent when you look at someone
like Mulaney
I mean he's so cocksure that it's hard
to imagine him struggling no it looks
like he just came out fully baked and he
sort of did there are anomalies and
that's important and we sort of talked
about that with Joe Buki jubu keys in
his 20s and he's fantastic
and so one of the things that people
like me that had to develop and grow and
earn it and that's 99.9% of us you have
to guard yourself and open your heart to
people like Mulaney that are just he
speaks in bits uh-huh you're just like
Oh
everything you say is funny and you're
not like you're not I I don't feel a
clenched it's like that off-camera - oh
my god every time Jon and I hang out
here's my impression of me I go that's a
bit I just tell him he doesn't need me
to tell him but I mean everything he
says it's just really funny and when he
was young
I remembered John had a bad set I hope
he wouldn't mind me saying one time we
saw him have a bad set
and I remember Birbiglia said to him I
was like you know it's kind of good is
because it sort of humanizes you right
because we're all over here going like
what is happening with this person right
and what is the the secret sauce with
Judd like what is he what's the magic
that he brings to a show like yours when
he sprinkles his special fish you know
yeah it fairy dust oh yeah it's an
interesting thing he's a wonderful
collaborator and he was involved in
everything and he was very good at
trusting his instincts I think one of
the reasons why it can be difficult I
have a friend
my friend Duncan Trussell is starting a
show and he was like I don't get it man
people show me to two ideas and they're
both good and they asked me to pick one
and I'm like what I learned from
watching Jed and he would say this if he
were here is you just learned to kind of
trust your gut
Jed would go it's this and it's like but
couldn't we have talked for 20 minutes
about how it could have been that or two
hours or two days about how it could
have been the other and he's sort of
learned how to listen to his small still
voice and he would [ __ ] hate that I
made it a Quaker thing I'm just saying
he's learned to trust his instincts and
that's why so many of his projects have
the same flavor and you know what else
he does is sometimes he knows to go
against his instincts he knows every
fifteenth I'm making that up but every
fifteenth time to the the opposite do
the George Costanza and do the opposite
of what you think so he knows to even
keep himself on his heels I could talk
much more about that if you'd like I
mean it's it's hard to sort of put what
he does in a in a nutshell is there an
example where you had a strong
inclination like the scene should play
like this or this arc should look like
this and he's like no it needs to be
cuts like this and that's really good
for me yeah I'm an idea person I would
write scripts and Jed would you know I'd
sometimes have like a fit of mania and
write a script and just show it to him
and be like it seems like a season three
idea at season one he's like this seems
like a season three idea and I'm good
with that I just go okay right I don't I
don't fight I don't debate so it works
it was a good relationship like I
especially when you respect somebody's
body of work so much it's very it's a
privilege to go it's a no okay move on
instead of go like I can get real upset
about it but there's a good example in
the third season where my character I
wrote it sort of sappy I can be a little
bit romantic and sometimes Jed would
steer me a little bit away from the
sappy melodrama stuff and Pete and Ali
obviously is this like sort of will they
get back together thing and in the first
episode of the third season I have it
written that Pete's auditioning at the
cellar and he bombs or he doesn't bomb
he does well but he doesn't get in and
that was tricky to do we could talk
about that but the the sort of silver
lining is that Ali came to me it's this
like sign that she came
so he's supposed to come out and he's
upset but then he realizes that Ali was
there to watch and there's this sort of
like loaded message underneath that that
maybe she still Italy's likes him as a
person or loves him as a friend and I
had it written very sweet like you know
the violence well and at least this girl
that I'm still secretly having feelings
for is here and Jed was there that day
and he was like we did shoot at the
sweet way and then he was like you
should do it where you just have a fight
and you get mad because you're taking
the frustration of your failure out on
her because that's sometimes what people
do with people that they have that's
more human and that's what jet does
so Jed that's what that's what I would
say even though he had read the script
even though he's at the table read even
though he read the rewrite and he
approved it and he was involved on the
day he'd go getting a fight she's
getting a fight yeah and and I didn't
even like doing it huh because even as
an actor I like getting along with me
boss and now I'm going like [ __ ]
thanks thanks and that's not easy for me
to do and it was so much better and he
would do that a million times every
season he would he would go I know
everybody's saying and sometimes he was
the only one he was like the one juror
that was like I think they're innocent
uh and would make them go and I don't
know what that was what always played in
the Edit room yeah hmm but what would
happen was I was very good you know at
going some of my friends would be like
shouldn't you fight more and I was like
I understand Jed night last night we're
joking that there was another version of
my last set at the cellar where I get
very Rob Bell with it and I talk about
how we're you know you know floating on
a planet and how we're all so alone and
we don't know what's going on and and it
was funny but it was mostly like
transcendent right and it was great with
the background actors we all felt that
it was this very like dipped in set like
very emotional set and we all thought
that that was like the right way to and
then and then Jed was like no you should
just be funny and it's almost too much
like she was too evolved that's what he
said Missy's like he can't do that yeah
if he does ideas know where to go this
is his first moment like just can't nail
a few jokes so he would help me stop me
from being too precious he's like yeah
it's really great and he means that he's
like it's really great that you can go
up and make people think deep thoughts
and and get everybody in the moment
which is really what I think I did in
that set but that's like heat homes now
exactly exactly
that's not he but the bread that to give
you an idea I joked with him last night
he was like because we watched that
episode he was like and I was like it
what is better what you said was better
and he was like he fought me and I said
and I fight you you mean I brought it up
politely twice hahaha and that's and he
laughed because that I don't think
that's one of the reasons why he and I
worked well together is I don't know if
it has something to do with my
psychology and how I was with my parents
I think it probably does but I was very
okay with going like you know he told me
on a Friday like we're gonna cut this
even though I really loved it
and I sort of kept my mouth shut and
then over the weekend I just unpacked it
and on Monday I was just like fine with
it even though all the editors knew I
loved it and stuff they knew I must have
been disappointed but it's great to have
somebody with that heavy a crown or that
shiny a crown to kind of yield to well
let's talk about your parents okay I'm
getting into your book in fact this just
came in the mail like an hour I
delivered it like an hour ago
I really I don't know it was the wrong
really so that's yeah just arrived today
but you sent me the PDF oh yeah I sent
you the the PDF I had a moment talk
about dealing with suffering in real
time I had to practice what I write
about in this book because I sent me the
wrong galley I was and it was like the
second draft or something and I was
really did that go out to pound up I was
afraid that it had but I think we caught
it before it did it looks like this is
not that version but there were like
chapter titles that were I'm sure I
don't know if you do this when you write
books I would write a phrase it was fool
king it's one word it's not a word it
meant I had to go back to that part like
I'd write fool King just so I could do a
funny note to yourself and I do yeah I
search for that phrase and then I go
right I have to fix it and the book
included some fool kings in fact right
one of the chapters was called
fool King the chapter about meeting
about Ram Dass meeting Maharaja was
called fool King and I was like guys
that you know I again I sort of did what
I did
I said to Valerie I'm very upset and
then I went in the bedroom because
sometimes I don't know I'm a little
overwhelmed with that emotion and I did
what I did what I write about in this
book and I tried to say yes thank you to
suffering in real time uh-huh not later
and go oh okay I get it the universe is
sort of nudging me away from being so
precious and important and my book and
like the baby picked me up like in the
and I in real time even though I didn't
intellectually believe this
I said yes thank you to the suffering
and when you give it that space it
really does have nowhere to cling to and
it dissipates and then my wonderful
editor Luke Luke Dempsey said we'll
change it I didn't even ask him to he
said it'll change him it's an amazing
thing when you do have the capacity to
let go in real time like that is that
fun actually it's a it's a short circuit
to the solution that you seek yeah and
it's in the struggle on the fighting it
that actually delay it's right the
result that you're giving your suffering
Mooji the great saint talks about like
when you have a thought the only thing
that can give that thought power or
validity is you it's just for you so
here it is it's just this firing of your
brain but your awareness and your
consciousness can can give it value or
not so I'm having all these valid
rational real objections to the second
draft and it's legitimate you just spent
three years writing this book but you
have to you have to just go it's
irrational
it's how I love my wife our wedding
bells I said I vow to love you
irrationally I don't want rational love
get the [ __ ] out of my face with that
[ __ ] 7-eleven by the register
[ __ ] conditional love that I can get
from anybody being special and shiny
suck my dick
I want that irrational stuff I want that
trans rational stuff the real stuff yeah
the stuff that's holding your molecules
together that's a love even when you're
being shitty it's still keeping you rich
fuckin'-a I hope so I mean yeah yeah
it's pretty exciting um one of the
things you talk about in the book I'm
like 70 pages into it so I just started
that's fine I've done a reviews on less
I've got eyes and blown them away with
how much I understood their book and I
only read the first chapter but they're
like blown away cuz if I recently I can
rather almost everything into my car
it's like this the worst is when
somebody tries to play themselves off as
having read it thinking they're gonna
get away with it
yeah author yes so clear to that person
who wrote it of course of course that
happens on talk-show yeah you just have
to give cuz you know they're doing a
show every day
in fairness yeah like they can't
possibly when I had a doctor they used
to give you a book and it would be
highlighted uh-huh with little post-its
and stuff so you could just read them so
you could act smart yeah Reader's Digest
right but back to your mom and your dad
yeah
so what's interesting is that your dad
was kind of the you know regaling funny
man yeah and it would be easy to say
well this is who you got your comedic
inspiration from but it was really the
alchemy with your mom and her
Sensibility I think you get more of it
from your mom even though she wasn't a
comedian or a funny person she's very
honest yeah it's that honesty that
willingness to be honest right that is
the defining mark of a good comedian
yeah I agree I got what I got from my
dad was my dad goes in a room almost
like a Salesman or a politician and
changes the temperature of the room not
in a in a show hey get out of here way
you just noticed he's a big planet and
he becomes the center of gravity in a
way that you sort of enjoy it on us in
the way that it's like hey follow me you
know what I mean and you like it so I
would watch him and I don't mean in
high-stakes situations necessarily I
wasn't there for those cuz I was a kid
but if he went into a bakery suddenly it
just became the neighborhood bakery he
was just sort of the mayor of Somerville
where he worked most of the time and
he'd go in and I would just watch how it
wasn't impolite to sort of change the
frequency of a room it was actually
welcome people it's like a party you
know what I mean when when there's one
person at a party that makes it a party
yeah and and as someone now I've thrown
parties and whatever you know how badly
you want something to get on the
personality this is a party mmm we're
having fun and I learned that from my
dad and Valerie my wife has pointed out
that I have that quality too especially
when I'm pitching something or when I'm
doing stand-up I can sort of
a lesson to one thing instead of 300
individuals and a comedian we just
become a show and that and that's a
quality that I learned for my dad my dad
does tell a lot of jokes and it made me
think that jokes are important my mother
would always put the funny pages out for
us like because we liked it but she read
them too so like jokes were like
important and joking around was
important but my mother was just still
is the sort of person that will point
out that my my friend that she hasn't
seen in 20 years his hair is receding or
whatever it's just like I you don't have
as much hair whatever it is they're like
wow and like what's funnier I know know
what joke or the or the like the just a
little stab of honesty that comes in an
unexpected way somebody that's not
playing by the rules it's Kramer its
Kramer on Seinfeld it's just like and
you need a crane run side felt to tell
the story you need someone that like
Kramer goes you just need a nose job
remember that moment that's my mom and I
did I did learn that and also there she
was religious obvious she is religious
but she also like gets a like almost
offended or bewildered if someone
doesn't understand that she's joking
that's why I said lighten up was a
mantra and so was can't you take a joke
like they just don't get it right it's
almost like a dysfunction she doesn't
understand why you would be upset that
she's saying something but is she aware
that she's being funny I think so yeah I
think it comes from the place of the
painting and the you know wanting to
feel and not a bad way but the feeling
of like I don't want to keep that in
here I want you to reflect me back to me
which a lot of artists have that it's
like I want to say what I'm thinking and
see what you think and then I'll know
myself and you a little bit better so I
think she had that and has that she's a
little bit like an artist and write the
mantra that I think you adopt and you
point this out in the book is this idea
of like what is this like where what
yeah what is going on like the sense at
a very young age where you're walking
around and everyone's living their lives
and you have this like undeniable
sensibility of awe and wonder about the
world
what is actually happening on this crazy
you know spinning blue thing we're out
in space and you know the sky is up but
it's also sideways and also below and
and this is just confused why no one
wants to talk about that yeah right and
that ultimately seems to be you know in
addition to your mother's impetus like
what leads you into the church and where
you you know find a home for you know
debating and talking about these things
that also then informs your comedy yes I
still wonder why we're talking about you
know [ __ ] I get it sometimes it's
exhausting to talk about what is this
but just in the way that you don't seem
to mind like swimming with a weight belt
on like I don't wanna do that I'd be
like I don't tire as easily just kind of
wondering even right now as we're
speaking like what is what is going on
here I like it it kind of excites me
there's an exhausting way to do it where
you're really thinking about it we're
really going like let's really
conceptualize what's going on and then
there's a way that's almost like thought
less where you're just sort of yielding
to a mystery that we're a part of and
that's not as tiring it's hiring to go
like look the dust looks like the solar
system that's almost like writing poetry
in your brain and that will get tiring
but there's like a almost like a
quietness where you're going like like a
dream like I'm a lucid dreamer and
whenever I have a lucid dream I'm like
it looks just like reality that's like
[ __ ] crazy and you can you can bring
that wonder into your waking life as
well there was more about dreams in the
book mom but my editor right Leigh was
like no one cares about dreams so I was
like you're right
I don't know i caressed there's some
well that's because you're interested
but the what is this was was my thing as
a kid and it manifested in being very
interested in UFOs and Bigfoot and us
ESB and all these different you
immediately popular very unpopular and
comedy comedy is also like you know
comedy is like playing operation we're
trying to figure out where the
boundaries of socialness on a lie and
then that what is this kind of got
funneled into the church and what I
liked about the church was we didn't
debate as much but at least they said
God which I liked
I enjoyed that they had an answer that
was different from well I don't know eat
your [ __ ] tacos you know who cares we
got to get to school it was nice that
they were saying God because God was
something I make a comparison in the
book where I was leaving a superhero
movie and I heard a kid say to his dad
dad how do they make that man fly and
the dad without really thinking about it
just went computers and I was like it's
very funny cuz computers really just
means I don't know you just say I don't
know and in the same way God might mean
I don't know but at least it was
something at least it gave us a symbol
and something to explore and unpack if
you're feeling curious computers or God
it gave gave me a foothold into the
mystery and then when I came into the
church this is the sex part
I sort of also received a lot of
information that wasn't welcome yeah I
mean now is the cracks in the firmament
from the get-go yeah right my sexuality
and I'm a straight person so what I'm
saying is it wasn't like I guess you I
don't want to call it normal but I mean
like straight white guy you think that
would be pretty normal but in the church
you almost feel like you have to come
out as straight you're like I like
vagina is like a dirty it's also bad
like everything's but it's all bad it's
all anything about it as bad so you get
this shame that people might not
understand like right here we got we uh
yes yes so you're having I'm holding up
Nadia's Nadia Bowles Weber's new book
shameless she's going up on the podcast
tonight she's amazing she's doing your
podcast tomorrow yeah so her whole this
new book that she just came out with is
all about that I know and when I was
reading through you know your youth in
high school and what you experienced I
mean you're the white male version of
what she talks about in here but imagine
you're you're trans or you're gay and
and just what that shame and that guilt
you know right must feel like for those
people but that's why even as a straight
white male I relate and empathize and my
heart opens to people who for example
they're trans because we're all taking
the information the emotional and the
psychological and the personal
information inside and we want to be
acknowledged and
for what we really are and even if you
are just a straight white man there's
still some of that uncovering and
self-love that needs to happen and go
like it's okay that I want to jerk off
three times a day or whatever it was I
mean I really thought I was I right
about thinking that Jesus was gonna come
back while I was trying to come right
and it was it was very that's that's
almost it's almost like child abuse it
kind of is yeah what I liked in the book
is your mother your mom's honesty
shining through when you're there trying
to you're asking these questions that
everyone's too afraid to ask like is it
okay for me to masturbate can I do this
right and everyone is like freaking out
I didn't like raising the issue that's
right in church they would just say the
closest we would get is saying lust you
just be like lust lust let's talk about
lust but we never really talked about
lust or like that's that's a big that's
a big part of my psychology is blessed
and and my you know for whatever reason
we were just too polite or whatever to
talk about it directly and I really
needed help and when you sort of left to
your own devices with verses like if you
look at a woman with lust in your heart
you've committed adultery which Jesus
says and then why I asked my youth
pastor of masturbation if I had
masturbated it was I still a virgin
and and he said technically and I was
like well I'm technically going to
heaven like I'm technically okay like
one of the big things in the book was I
wasn't tempted to lie or cheat or steal
or hurt people or murder anybody but I
had like undeniable throbbing biological
urges and a fresh batch of them every
morning and that is where you sort of
get an unhealthy bond between God and
and sex and an unnatural feeling that
that was exactly how you were loved or
unloved or heaven or hell or accepted or
unaccepted and and the journey of the
book is among other things learning to
accept that part of myself and and every
part of myself but you stayed in it for
quite a long time I mean it leads you
into a marriage you know got a big part
of your story yep with what happened
there and it took a long time for you to
kind of reconcile all of this it did I
mean
you haven't gotten to it but I mean
eventually I pushed it down a number of
ways one of them was just the Oscar
Wilde says the only way to get rid of
temptation is to yield to it
and I had a huge portion of the book I
become an atheist in the book and then I
I just sort of enjoy that time still
engaging with my what is this but
without a symbol system or a metaphor or
story so I was still a decent person but
I was like I'm done beating myself up
about sex or being horny or this or
whatever it might be I had some random
sex that was very healing for me and I I
thought I had sort of gotten it all out
and then at the end when I go and sit
with Rahm Das and a personal retreat
which is sort of how the book end I
realized that like all that stuff was
still in there there needed to be a more
radical acceptance you can go like
compartmentalize the shame and the guilt
exactly I and I and I had sort of given
the werewolf a pork chop basically I was
just like here you go but really what
the word werewolf wanted was love it
will love is what we're saying not going
like you're virile and you're a young
man and it's part of life it's the ABCs
everybody does it that's not good enough
it needs to be shut up I love you period
that's it
and not I'm thinking about loving you I
mean like an energy like a heart energy
that I'm sure you've dipped into and dip
into every day there's a spaciousness
that we can feel and participate I call
that spaciousness God I call that flow
and that energy in that space god it's a
beautiful thing to play with but you had
to go on that journey I don't you
arrived at that place where you could
sit at the the feet of Rama das and have
him deliver that message to you and you
could accept that that's right you know
it's all in the game and it's it's sort
of like these are different versions of
crashing right you crash in your life
that's various ways we wanted to do some
G yourself slow it down and and and it's
all in the game and I used to think
losing your faith that was the worst
thing you can do and there's Jesus
saying you have to lose your faith you
lose your life to find it right and I
would say you have to lose your faith to
find it the cracks Leonard Cohen says
that's where the light comes through I
was to think God was asleep at the wheel
when my wife
ma'am now I'm now you look back and
you're like Oh for [ __ ] sake it was
all it was all the day off for you it
was all for me who I was gonna be for
even even my dad though that's not a
failure you know what I'm saying it's
not just about prosperity gospel it's
not and then I got a TV show I'm talking
about something way more important which
is an inner transformation and an
enlightening feeling you know to me in a
place our society our culture is so
organized around this principle of like
creating this happy you know drama-free
life of success and prosperity and ease
and luxury yeah but the truth is the the
grit and the beauty is found in that
struggle and ie to the extent that you
know I don't I don't I don't wish ill
will on anybody but you know anybody
who's gone through their version of you
know they're they're kind of crashing
yeah whether it's spiritual or physical
or emotional there are lessons to be
mine wouldn't and that is the stuff of
life Ramdas says in his Netflix
documentary which if people don't know
around us it's a great place to start
it's called going home I believe and he
says I don't wish you the stroke he had
a stroke and Indies he goes I don't wish
you the stroke I wish you the grace from
the stroke and also it's important to
know when people are suffering it's not
helpful for you to go in and go wow this
is grace but it's been very helpful for
me to update my understanding of the
divine that's inclusive of everything
otherwise we're just my therapist would
say there's a big pile of [ __ ] in the
room and or just spraying Febreze on it
you know I mean you need to find I
needed to discover on my own and through
personal experience a model of the
universe and of the mystery we don't
have to call it God just what's
happening what is this that includes
suffering and I didn't have that we had
we I remember my pastor my first
suffering you're doing it wrong exactly
and if you're suffering we're just gonna
if someone dies we just go well they're
in heaven but we were just praying our
eyes out that they would be healed and
then they died so I guess God knows
drunk that morning you know any mean no
what were you doing it's like Buddhism
it's like you're already dead the cups
already broken like what are you gonna
do what how are you gonna
like Ryan holiday would say the stoicism
of it it's like you can't change the
game that we're a part of you can change
how you respond to it and how you
interpret it and how you interact with
it from inside so what led you to ROM
das how did you find yourself drag him
out a lot of psychedelics not a lot I've
only done psychedelics under ten times
probably in my life but they will talk
about it before though they've I mean
they're very important I mean you can
only get hit by a car once it's gonna be
a low number but a high impact on your
life and I I didn't know that when I
took mushrooms for the first time so
basically the the the bullet points
would be my wife left me I grew up in
the church I got very into it I thought
I was gonna be a youth pastor I went to
Christian College all this stuff end up
becoming a comedian anyway the book
opens with a joke my mom said close
enough I was gonna be a priest I became
a comedian she said close enough and
then very funny by the way she's funny
it's the first thing in the book first
joke in the book well the first joke in
the book is some of the names have been
changed to have my ex-wife which I was
proud of her um but uh then I lose my
faith because my wife leaves me and I
felt like I had been paying protection
money to God I think a lot of people
feel this way like the Mafia and yet
still someone had thrown for the fifth
time a brick through my bakery window
I'm like what am I paying this guy for
you know I mean I I'm his she Shepherd
me sheeps don't have their wife sheep
get [ __ ] by a wolf like you [ __ ] up
that's how I felt so he broke his he
didn't hold up his end of the bargain in
my sort of third grade second grade
kindergarten understanding of God so as
I forget it you know I also think I was
having doubts that you know sort of I
was allowed to feel after my wife left
me I was sort of allowed to let them I
used to think thinking doubts was a sin
so I would push those away as well but
then when I had lost what felt like
everything I was sort of freed to look
at those doubts in those feelings for
the first time without the fear of the
idea being like look I was a good
soldier I did all these things I went
you know the extra mile to adhere to all
the insanity and I repaid in this way
that's right I brought non-alcoholic
beverages to party
there were khakis I played the bass in
the worship team I like when you're
trying to recruit people in your high
school yeah I mean is there anything
worse yeah you barely have your feet on
the ground of what you think is
salvation and then you're supposed to go
out and sell it it was only the most
unpleasant thing you're all like 16 but
that was one of the things is when my
wife left I had to take a real hard look
at like do you really believe that like
the example I use in my book is my
brother is going to hell he didn't
believe like I did do you really believe
that like really really think about it
and I was like well my behavior is maybe
more honest than my thoughts and my
behavior I what was very clear I wasn't
really actively grabbing him going you
fool there's a train coming right and
you're on the tracks you idiot I I
wasn't doing that I was having tacos
with him tacos again but uh so then I
lose it and then I'm out in the wild and
I start kind of feeling growing up a
little bit and all these kind of
interesting things and then I took
mushrooms with my girlfriend at Bonnaroo
and we just thought it was like
something fun to do I wasn't a big drug
person I'm not a big drug person I
hadn't done a lot of drugs I'd probably
smoke pot like I don't know 15 times in
my life at that point and then we bought
some mushrooms from a roadie and we went
on the ferris wheel and I at the time I
would not have said that I experienced
the divine what I did experience was
something that was completely beyond
language so what we're saying it was
trans rational it didn't make any sense
it wasn't something I thought it was
something that I became and this this
sounds like if you read other people
writing about mystical experiences
that's what they say you can think I am
made of the same molecules as this table
and as you and yet here are two
consciousnesses talking to each other
it's [ __ ] trippy but to become that
that will lay you on your back and it
did and I laid there now with a cape
staring at the clouds and receiving like
direct real even after I had come down
real transmission from the universe
grabbing me and saying we're so glad
you're finally [ __ ] here so you can
put down your briefcases filled with
your precious little beliefs and you're
in I'm in
I'm a Christian I'm in get all that [ __ ]
out of here
lay the [ __ ] down on some grass and
stare up towards infinity you idiot
which is always there you idiot
and really like listen to me for a
second stop praying by thinking God help
me find parking god help me beat that
flu that's going around and listen shut
up for a second so turn your brain off
for us and that just plays directly into
your main thing which is what is that
exactly you know and I was finally
getting a taste and it was through
something it wasn't from as Richard Rohr
would say it wasn't from doing it right
abstaining from drugs from doing it
wrong what a beautiful paradox God hides
himself in pain and strange wayward
afternoons in Tennessee that's [ __ ]
gorgeous that's amazing so I did
mushrooms and then I realized that there
was some there were some things that we
can't really talk about right there are
things that are beyond language Terence
Mckenna says there are things that are
that we can't talk about oh how does he
say it there are things that are beyond
language they're just so damn hard to
talk about it's basically what he says
so I experienced that I realized that
that is a reality and that is a reality
that there are almost like magical
things like magic is real and like
wonder is real and it's not just some
cute feeling we sometimes get at the end
of a Pixar movie like it's a [ __ ]
real thing that's happening and more
importantly was it's impossible to put
into words and then I started my heart I
didn't know had opened up to the
potential that the writers of things
like the Bible were also trying to use
myth and metaphor because as Richard
Rohr says metaphor is the only language
we have to talk about God that doesn't
mean it's not true it means it's so big
and vast and mysterious that how else
are you gonna talk about it I'm sorry to
be so aggressive but like you're gonna
talk about it directly you're gonna talk
about it like the contents of your
refrigerator you're gonna add it to your
Amazon wishlist the mystery of
everything you can't talk about it
directly you can talk about it through
music sex drugs poetry and metaphor so
then I meet Joseph Campbell and because
I started doing my podcast and this guy
named Matt Ruby was like because I
started sharing my story and the more
that I shared the more I was getting
feedback you could say from the universe
I'll just say from my friend Matt Ruby
he emails and he's like I think he'd
really like
Joseph Campbell and then I start reading
the Bible as a myth overlaid over
history who cares I'm so boring it's
true okay get out of here you're just
okay eat your ice cream is this what
brings you to rob bell what's
interesting is is you know there are
other people with similar versions of
your story that leads to them you know
abandoning their their past and their
relationship with Christianity
altogether and they may find themselves
at the feet of Rama das but then it's a
whole exploration of mysticism that
never leads them back to kind of
reclaiming a different relationship with
that text that started it yeah yeah I
find that deeply and admittedly
psychologically very beneficial if it's
all one it's all one right but I just
happen to have ties to Jesus I like
Christ all right the Jesus story the
Jesus I come from the Jesus tradition
but I like that so there wasn't there
was a period there was much more about
Rob in the first draft of the book it
was just getting too crazy I can't
summarize Love Wins and Richard Rohr and
Rhonda and that's what the first that's
another book it isn't I mean you could
you could write a whole book on that I
absolutely okay yeah great book would be
like Tuesdays with Maurey cuz I used to
go and surf with Rob every weekend right
and I could I wish I had been journaling
at that time honestly I just didn't
realize how exceptional and wonderful it
was
I could tell but I wasn't thinking like
how could I share this with people yet
but I would do it kind of in real time
on the podcast but that so once I opened
up the idea that Jesus's death and
resurrection for example is a metaphor
for your death your ego death and your
resurrecting to the dynamic source of
all being so you need to wake up to to
Christ consciousness basically suddenly
it wasn't about worshiping someone
else's story I write about in the book
like Jesus was you're you're on a
football team with Jesus and he does
this incredible return after a pun or
whatever I don't know for now so he
catches the ball and he runs it back to
like his own 30 yard line but then he
gets tackled and the ball splits out and
falls in your arms and instead of like
running with the ball you put the ball
down so you can what block G was amazing
Jesus and Jesus is going you go this
story isn't about me it's about you and
worshiping someone else's story isn't
gonna do [ __ ] for you like we need you
to do it you die you die you know what
I'm saying all passionate about this no
I know what is you know it's one thing
like I believe this so I'm in a club is
way different from going oh I saw what
he did I'll do it too
I can't literally raised from the dead
and I can't literally heal the blind and
I can't literally turn water into wine
but I can metaphorically and I can I
have and I do and you do too
yeah and that's what we're supposed to
be doing the distinction between the
institution of religion and Christ
consciousness is a crevasse that's so
vast you know and it's you know I just
look at it as if you know just
introducing human beings into an
organizing principle around this you
know exceptional human being or the
ideas that he represents immediately
corrupts it fast forward to young Pete
Holmes you know being told all these
things about his sexuality that I feel
terrible about well that's I think
Duncan told me this but I think Ram Dass
also it's just a joke it doesn't belong
to anybody I guess but the guy God and
the devil why is it that devil but just
God God in the devil's ik that's a bit
yeah the devil well he has more of an
ego so it's like it's good devil gods
like I finally just got it's fine
Travis is uh just devil like Facebook
yeah which is the devil I'm just kidding
it kid me listen they're walking down
the street I don't know why and they see
God sees on the ground a little piece of
truth and he picks it up and he's like
when I look at this truth and the devil
says give it to me I'll organize it
which is what we're dealing with like I
think the enormity of these things and
my heart goes out to these people
because I I was one of them and can
completely understand but our ego wants
to wear the jersey and be in the club
and
think that we're right and it's all
nationalism and clam thinking and and
personal salvation and [ __ ] everybody
else like kind of quietly kind of
feeling that way and I don't think Jesus
came to start a religion I don't think
that's even controversial to say Rob
would say Jesus would be appalled that
there's a religion because he went
around going it's right here
you know it's right here there's a lot
more of that stuff in the Gospel of
Thomas and stuff which isn't in the
Canon but there's certainly a lot of it
in the Gospel of John what's interesting
about Nadia and you'll find this out
when you when you talk to her is you
know she shares so much of that same
perspective and yet she's also very much
a traditionalist like she remains within
the institution as a pastor in the
Lutheran Church right and reconciling
those two things like these progressive
ideas about what these stories mean how
we interpret them and and incorporate
their wisdom into our lives versus the
institution itself and she's found a way
to coexist within that right that's
interesting that that's definitely one
of my questions for her and for Richard
Rohr who is going to do my podcast again
it's like some people beautifully remain
in the tradition my thing is around us
thing and it's in the book as he says
you don't want to be Christian you want
to be free and you don't want to be
Jewish you want to be free and as long
as you know what you want is
consciousness without an object you want
no separation between you and God so I
write this story in the book about how I
used to go to museums wrong cuz I'd go
I'd look at a painting to think about it
ago this is fewer colors than other
paintings I've seen this is more colors
this is bigger than others I've seen I
could do that I could do that it's
definitely one of them or these are the
good ones cuz I look down and I see it's
a Picasso or I go this is a good one I
think it's Monet but it's MANET and I'm
like it's not good it's it's [ __ ]
it's head stuff so like I don't want
that I want to completely merge beyond
subject and object where God and I are
just coexisting seamlessly in us in an
unspeakable way so how do you get to
that place I mean we talk I definitely
talk about that in the book one of them
is through practice and I don't just
mean
meditating and yoga or whatever it might
be I I think it can come one of the big
things for me is contemplation talking
about it
remembering to remember is a big one
because it's a little bit more
effortless than sometimes we make it
sound I think a lot of people get turned
off when I say well you need to meditate
twice a day every day or whatever and
they're just like I can't
and then they don't but we all
occasionally slip into these states I
know I'm not just saying this because
it's you extreme physical activity or
just swimming in the ocean or having sex
these are these are little glimpses or
near-death experience I think it's about
removing the barriers that we've all
constructed in our own minds and our own
consciousness is like if you you know as
a comedian as an artist you know full
well that you know the the the value of
the script that you write for crashing
is not going to be is not going to
directly correlate to like how hard you
work on it right you if you grind on it
and you pull all nighters that's doesn't
necessarily mean it's gonna be good
it might be and probably will be better
if you can just get into a space of
stillness where you can kind of channel
what's already inside of you that's
right and in an effortless way that's
right and it might not feel like you did
anything but then the truth will be
there and that might be the thing that
elevates that's right so it's it's about
like stripping away losing something
right not gaining the right belief but
losing something and I you know I say
this in the book - I I think that the
devil can be a metaphor for your brain
or your ego because we used to call the
devil a liar and a thief and I think
it's my brain and my thoughts that are
often thieving me and lying to me and
it's the same thing when I'm in the
museum thinking about a painting is not
the same as merging with the painting so
I say don't consume a flower be consumed
by it and there's methods in the book
that I talked about and they're very
simple and I don't mind spilling them
but it's a lot of times it's about
giving your brain something to do one of
the chapters is just called yes thank
you that's very valuable to me I think
it's worth I don't know if the books
like 25 bucks I think that's worth it
and I hear it here it is for free it'll
be cheaper on Amazon
exactly it'll be cheaper in the bargain
bin a bomber but yes thank you is a very
very powerful mantra it doesn't have to
be in Sanskrit it doesn't have to be
woowoo or something that might not feel
natural to you yes thank you is super
super valuable and we talked about
earlier with suffering you say yes thank
you to that well there's all these paths
towards that there you can use the
traditions of you know the Jesus story
and its ancillary stories you can find
it in the wisdom of ROM das and you can
find you know it's it's analogous to a
lot of the stoic philosophy - there are
many paths towards that absolutely truth
well there's no there's no greater joy
and I'm not just saying this then when I
find truth hiding in different people's
styles you know what I mean if I read
something I'm reading Richard Rory's new
book which is called the the eternal
Christ and I'm also reading Alan
Watson's book called this is Ed and it's
the same book you know what I mean and I
mean that in the great way obviously
they're using different symbols but
they're talking about the same things
and that really lights me up and then
when Ryan comes on and talks about
stoicism which I didn't even really know
much about and I'm like oh they were
saying the same thing that the Buddhists
were saying but like the Buddha did that
he held up a flower that was his great
sermon is you're just you know a car toy
says you know crystals are enlightened
rocks and flowers are enlightened beings
because they're like beautiful for no
reason they've just sort of figured out
like well they might as well do this
this is like a beautiful flower and that
is a much more powerful sermon than me
trying to get you to think and and
absorb the same symbols and stuff so the
Christ story still works for me
meditation is wonderful psychedelics are
still occasionally very helpful to me
but I one of the things that I really
enjoy a lot is using the mind to beat
the mind there's a type of yoga that if
I was really smart I would remember the
name of the type of yoga that is but
your brain is a certain power yoga nidra
Yoga Nidra is that you may know maybe
I'll I didn't make it up it doesn't
sound good
but uh I like contemplation I like
reading things and stopping and looking
out the window or staring at a tree and
that's where everything fits so if
somebody was to say to you you know Pete
how do you define your faith how do you
canonize it
to you how do you articulate your
perspective on these things I'm a Christ
leaning spiritual seeker person I still
enjoy that because for better or worse
those those things got in there and
weren't imprinted on me when I was young
so I get very excited when I can reclaim
those stories and and bring them with me
and not throw the baby out with the bath
but um a lot of it you know I spent so
much of my life thinking how to be more
like Jesus would wear those bracelets to
say what WWJD what would Jesus do we
wanted to be like Jesus as if Jesus
liked the point of Jesus was how nice he
was and how he got along with everybody
and when people say how can I be more
like Christ I'm like when you know like
in in between each of those words I
think you're probably closer than you
think you know when we can stop and turn
the volume down this is very unpleasant
ooh the ego when we think it's not about
having something it's about letting go
of something but stillness and quiet be
still and know that I'm God that it's
right there staring you in the face it's
it's about getting into your pure basic
awareness a big thing the book is about
is is is tapping into soul consciousness
it's so hard to be still these days I
know you know I know
you have to really be intentional about
it you have to go out of your way you
have to create roadblocks and boundaries
yeah otherwise the phone and the email
and just the digital landscape yes it
does into every time I be my struggle
get like an autoresponder it's like I'm
taking a break for me mail then you
write me back yeah
I try but I have to do that you know and
I and and I'm not very good at it like
it's become increasingly more and more
difficult to turn those things off yeah
and allow yourself to be bored but if
you don't create boredom for yourself
then as somebody who's a maker who's
making things yeah how do you make you
need that fertile soil you need the soil
to be fertile in order to do that you
have to carve out that space I like to
think of it like a pond like a koi pond
and if the waters too rocky you can't
even see the fish and the fish are your
ideas based but if the if the pond is
deep there's always still water
underneath it's always there
go swimming and find it yeah jump in
please have to go well those are so down
that's what psychedelics are I wish I
could do psychic dogs I can't I think I
know I don't drink anymore right no I I
consider myself me when I did your
podcast yeah you have a bunch of
questions about alcohol and then I'd
heard that you quit drinking so well you
can listen back to my podcast when I was
drinking and I anytime I talk to a sober
person I was just like you know so
blindly
so obviously curious about like what are
you doing because I didn't realize that
I was habitually addicted to it I like
to say I wasn't like a sexy drunk it was
just something that I had lost control
over sexy drunk meaning like I don't
have wild stories I have like kind of
sad stories about getting high from
doing stand-up I get that like good
natural high and then going home and not
knowing what to do with that so I would
drink enough vodka to kill one of your
dogs you know and that's not like a wild
story but like you realize I realized
one day I went home and I poured myself
a drink and I had never there was no
agency involved it was just something
that I do mm-hmm
like I don't know taking off your pants
before you get in the shower like which
is natural and I was like what I really
liked about the way that I stopped
drinking was people want to drink
because they have Liberty they're like
no one tells me what to do it's a real
human need as no one tells me I can't
have a mai tai right and then I would
and I really flipped it and I was like
no true Liberty is not letting something
that was like sold to you as relaxation
and and relief lie to you and and and
come in and steal your Liberty so I sort
of flipped at very one-for-one being
like true Liberty is going no you can't
wolf it's starting to happen is it's
starting to own you then yes certainly
you're not that's right
and you know I don't know you know
whether you're an alcoholic or not but
it's a it's a self diagnosed thing right
you know only you know whether it's
problematic for you and and it was it
was helpful for me I read a book called
this naked mind and I recommend it on
audiobook it's almost hypnotic and how
repetition at a repetitious it is huh
but um I liked that it didn't
necessarily for
better worse for me use alcoholic
non-alcoholic in the club out of the
club whatever it was it just like
alcohol is a deeply addictive thing and
you also have all this conditioning and
talks about advertising and the way the
story was kind of given to you and how
it is in our culture and I maybe my ego
liked it I don't know that it was like
you were you were had that's the summary
of that book you've been had and you
were able to just put it away yeah I
read that book and by the end I was done
hmm and I think but it was also because
when you were on I was talking about it
yeah so is he it's like we know it's
interesting cuz you were curious you're
like so you don't drink ever and would
anything make you dress like I don't
remember exactly you're asking me I was
like a brother very people are if I talk
to somebody last night he was like yeah
I haven't drank in a month I feel great
and I'm like that's fantastic and he was
like yeah I'm gonna start again next
month what are you why right it's this
really interesting thing there's a joke
yeah there's a joke in AAA that like
only the alcoholic would want to
celebrate like getting their one-year
chip getting year of sobriety by getting
drunk I tell ya that's really funny or
or like you know if I wasn't an
alcoholic I get drunk every day yeah
it's a weird mental it's interesting now
but I saw with food too you know I had
somebody do my podcast and he was
talking about like he he gave up
processed fast food and he was a real
addict to that stuff and then he was
like and he had lost all this weight and
he was basically juicing and all this
stuff it's interesting
Dave stone is his name and he was like
I'm really excited when the when the
year is up I'm gonna have my cheat days
or whatever and I was like I understand
but at the same time it's like you're in
this abusive relationship why are you
gonna spend one Saturday a week with
that person who beats you because human
I know and we can't lose touch with that
so when you talk about how it's hard to
be present I'm like great you're way
more useful to me this way hmm if you
were just sitting up by your beautiful
pool and telling me how easy or how
present you are it's not really useful
to me but if I can tell you if you get
in the shower you want to remember
memento mori oh right this is mori
memento mori remember that you died
that's a real hack and
the present and if you get in the shower
I do this and it works you get in the
shower and you say you can do it both
ways you can say this is my first shower
which is kind of true but you can also
say this might be my last shower right
it's a very it's an it's another way
that your mind Rob's from you as you go
it's Tuesday and it's morning and you
shower and you will on Wednesday and you
want Thursday you won't friend maybe not
I thought that on the ride over I was
like I could [ __ ] die on the way over
guess what I'm feeling the steering
wheel a little bit more in my fingers
and I'm hearing the music a little bit
more well I think I think you know in my
case there's probably a contingent of
people out there that project onto me
you know I've heard you do it already in
this podcast like oh rich goes and he
does these crazy athletic things and
he's mr. mindfulness and all of that
like you know just to be clear like I
these are things that I struggle
mightily with and I think there's power
and sharing that scores not saying like
oh here I figured it out and here's what
you do in your life will you know be
forever change take advice from me right
like I don't want if I never want to be
that guy I don't think of you that way
and and you know what I what I you know
gathered in the first 70 pages of your
book which is incredibly well-written
you're a great writer oh thanks really
well-written thank you cover Blair know
you're comfortable with a cover blur
well your editor spelled my name right
that's hilarious why did I spell it
wrong no no no I was making the joke
because oh that's got a second I took it
personally but but what's very clear is
is how on and this goes back to stand up
and you know what being a comedian is
all about which is being honest and
having that deep willingness to be
vulnerable and own yourself on stuff
that's like not comfortable yeah you
know what I mean and I went through that
when I wrote my book I realize like look
I'm not the most amazing athlete you
know like why is somebody gonna want to
read this book only to the extent that
they can connect with some strain of
humanity is the only way I'm gonna be
able to do that is if I have that
willingness to be on well that's well
I'm not a stand-up comedian but you know
I had to I had
I had to come to that place in order to
create something that would have any
kind of value of course that's it that's
why this book is almost embarrassingly
filled with fibroids and stories you
know jerking off I joke that it's called
comedy sex God because that's what it's
about but most of the sexes with myself
and then there's just so much shame and
embarrassment and and it's important to
note that even after I met Rahm dass the
first time and I learned how to meditate
and I learned what soul consciousness
was and and I done contemplation and I'd
learn breathing techniques and I had
learned yes thank you and all these
different things at work how many times
I would fall off and that this is the
sine wave of reality and that's very
valuable and that's where the energy is
is created I am not loved by those that
love me because I have the answers I'm
loved because I I don't know why but I
have to guess it has to do with my
honest of course and if everybody could
just like pause for a moment and really
think about that because I think to the
extent that we can all embody that a
little bit better I think the world
would be a better place I say to my dad
Point Blank because my dad is a very
classic dad and he really wants to be a
capital D dad to me and I'm like that
I'm 40 I'm almost 40 I can't wait to say
I'm 40
dad I'm 40 stop stop mmm and I my vows
my wedding vows they were like these
sort of almost coded messages sorted to
my dad from Vallon from me and he said
he really loved them I don't know if he
heard them but it was about how Val said
something like I love how you know real
strength is in sharing weakness and that
is so important to me I love that I grew
up with like a mountain of a dad but now
as I'm raising my I was like a dude's
dude right works on cars and yeah you
know isn't yes all that kind of he loves
the Red Sox and sports and all which is
fine and yeah and you can be into those
things and be deeply wonderful and he is
but admitting faults that so when I sent
this book the story when I go to
Rhonda's is that I get really really
really really really horny while I'm
there it's like I think it's a really
Wow
well the the conclusion is I thought
horniness was in the way of the teaching
the horniness was the teaching and
that's what I'm talking about when it
comes to like I needed to reconcile
with that I needed to love my fullness
and I don't mean think about loving my
fullness as I already said I mean just
being Montana sky just being spacious
irrational love to myself and getting in
touch with that part of myself and and
then obviously you know it when it went
away now that that was the point but
like I didn't find myself I joke in the
book I couldn't look at porn at Rhonda's
house the Wi-Fi password was maharajah
like I just wasn't comfortable doing it
so but it like these things are chasing
us and they all sort of want the same
thing the same thing that we're after we
can give ourselves and that's that's a
really powerful thing but the book is
there's a see the second season of
crashing I everything that I wrote about
in the book I already knew right but I
found myself deeply depressed going to
different liquor stores to mix it up
because a lot of them watch HBO so I
would you know mix up which liquor store
like yeah that would not be good so
that's factor the same now that I say it
it sounds like you're nuts alcohol
that's an alcoholic story yeah that
actually was helpful to me I was like
that sounds like a real AAA share right
yeah that I was aware that how much I
would drink I could drink like a pint of
vodka that would be like a normal
serving for me cuz I knew that wouldn't
give me a hangover this is real
alcoholic stuff know that I'm saying it
so that was after Ramdas you know I'm
saying that was after the methods and
the meditation and the techniques but I
got sloppy I had I say in the book I had
a nice little garden patch but then I
just stopped watering it this is what we
do but it's a practice that's what I
mean you don't go to Rahm Das and then
your problems are solved right you have
some dawning self-awareness that changes
everything and my problems aren't solved
now way but I see it as a game as the
dance in the play of the universe that
I'm participating in but I do kind of
see it from a different perspective I'm
less attached to it and I identify with
it less which is really helpful one of
the more powerful parts of the book I
talk about praying for peace and prayer
when I was growing up was thinking it
was just more thoughts like I would say
dear Jesus and that meant start
listening to my thoughts which were
going never-ending anyway but that just
meant like come in God and then it say
in Jesus name Amen
that meant you can go back to whatever
you were doing but I would just think
and I would say and I was an anxious kid
and I'm still an anxious person like I
just have sort of general anxiety but
when I was a kid I had a bald spot on
the side of my head I had like digestion
problems like the things that we
diagnose very quickly now oh you have
IBS and like back then I was just like
Oh Pete has gross farts but like I was
deeply deeply deeply anxious and so
whatever my parents are not on your head
from my stress compulsive like what I
didn't know wasn't talking it was it was
on the side I just went bald on the side
of my head Wow something that now 20-19
any kid that's you go to a specialist
right but in Boston in 1986 or whatever
was over yourself
get over yourself you [ __ ] I can't say
the words they would say my parents were
loving but it wasn't as like hyper aware
as we are now hopefully but um so
whenever my pastor would preach about
peace or the Lord being your shepherd or
whatever I would really pay attention
and I have this it's emotional for me I
remember singing the song called I cast
all my cares I cast all my cares upon
you I lay all my burdens down at your
feet at any time I don't know what to do
I cast all my cares upon you and I would
sing it out loud I would pray it
wouldn't work I'd open my eyes the
anxiety would still be there so I'd sing
it out loud
alone with stuffed animals way older
than I should have been there still have
stuffed animals
now it's terrible it didn't work I
really was trying to let go and to
accept peace from God that was very real
to me so it was a failure not only was
it not working and I really needed it
too but also I wasn't working because of
my lack of faith or I didn't mean it
enough I had all these like value
systems so soul consciousness is more
than just a fun thought experiment when
you can really go my awareness that's be
ah behind and beyond my identity and the
thought and the story that I build about
Who I am my gender where I'm from my age
my likes and my dislikes if you can
identify with the witness to those
things which is what meditation is it's
practice
being claimed pure awareness if you can
go into that place through breathing or
repetition of a mantra mantra that's
where pieces Rhonda says awareness is
peace that's peace when we say peace be
with you peace can only exist for a
moment in the ego because it's made of
stuff that will not allow for it this is
a quote in the book awareness is peace
so I say in the book it's one of my
favorite lines I say when I was a kid I
used to ask for peace now I go in and
get the [ __ ] and that's really
that's not isn't it fun to pretend we're
Souls because when we go to heaven we'll
get [ __ ] from unicorns that [ __ ]
ambrosia who cares
[ __ ] that [ __ ] we're here now okay and
and when I still little peep comes in to
visit me at night and I feel generalized
anxiety
it is not situation based it is not what
am I gonna do crashing was cancelled
home I'm gonna do it doesn't come that
way it just feels like what if they get
me that's what it feels like what if
they get me who's that it doesn't matter
what if they get me I write in the book
it's a it's a sensation usually reserved
for something pointy chasing you but
it's just a misfiring and it's happening
and it's real I used to go please take
this feeling away please take this
feeling away and now when I can get in
touch with my big eye you can realize
that this is just a story that you're
buying into and you can kind of slip
behind it and fall asleep
that's just practical as well it's a
mindfuck though because you can't you
can't try to let go the only way to let
go is to let go yeah and to get beyond
your story to become the observer to
step into you know the consciousness
that supersedes the machinations of the
thinking mind isn't allowing yeah right
and it contravenes every impulse and
instinct that we have to try to corral
our resources to get to a certain place
using our brains right so the the avenue
is much more delicate and nuanced and
ephemeral like there's you know it
requires somebody like Rama das in order
to explain it to us it doesn't even
after it being explained it doesn't land
immediately
so this is why
goes back to practice and and I'm I'm
right there with you and yet I'm not I
love the way I meditate but it's very
it's not very regimented it's not people
are like do you meditate every dandling
not really and then I'm on attention do
exactly what's your mantra and I'm also
like in another way I never stopped
meditating but like however you want to
frame it but like Mooji do you know who
Mooji is he's worth looking up on
YouTube and I love him because he is
he's a realised being and he just talks
about like he makes it sound not as
complicated like we've all heard and I
want to be clear that my book isn't
necessarily saying like if you want to
be able to turn off your mind and fall
asleep when the generalized anxiety
comes meditate for an hour every day a
lot of people will just go like why I
can and they're out Mooji and something
that I've learned from people like him
and from robbing us to are just like
well who's saying it I'm anxious who's
hearing you say who's witnessing
literally just stop and go I'm depressed
is the part of you that's noticing the
depression depressed well no that's just
this impartial it's like a flashlight
yeah shiny right well identify with that
and even if you can only do it for a
moment try doing that every time you're
feeling an unpleasant feeling you're
gonna get in a lot of reps do use your
language I'm just kidding I'm sorry I'm
trying to be funny but you know I'm
saying yeah that's something you
practice all the time so it doesn't have
to be sitting cross-legged and orange
robes and lighting incense just any time
you're like I'm anxious who's noticing
it that's why I did my in my stand-up
bed I was like sing happy birthday in
your head how are you hearing that what
is the thing behind the thing we all go
like I'm Pete and we think you're the
voice of cousin I am Pete really there's
a thing that was there between I'm Pete
and I'm hungry it was there and it's
always there and it's not anxious and
it's also not invested in your cute
little story or your TV show getting
canceled right it's just there and
that's peace and it's not as hard as it
sounds it's not something you
necessarily have to climb a mountain and
talk to Yogi did it get there just gonna
shake you and say you're already there
this is every story the box you're
sitting on as you're begging
is filled with gold what Saint Francis
says what you're looking for is what
you're looking with it's here it's here
not that that what the eyes can see but
that whereby the eyes can see that's
Brahman
that's the universal consciousness it's
[ __ ] amazing and it's the and the
more a depth you get at developing that
the more you realize that your thinking
brain is very good at during doing
certain rope things that get you through
the day and allow you to survive but
ultimately and in my case I can say like
most of the time any my friend that's
right it's just it's a party yes with
messages that don't serve me I want to
bring me down yeah yeah I'm hearing it
right now on hell what it's all I am I
gonna ask Pete max to look at you oh
yeah but I'll figure it out tell him how
you couldn't sleep last night or
whatever it might be and for somebody
who's listening who who is having a hard
time wrapping their heads around this
concept a little tweak mental tweak that
might help you is thinking about the
last time you had a dream and in that
dream you're having a conversation with
someone let's say you ask them a
question and you're awaiting their
response you don't know what they're
gonna tell you yeah and then they tell
you the answer and you're surprised yeah
in that fun that's how compartmentalized
our brains are right consciousness you
think you should lay it out like a yard
sale and you don't it's a secret so who
is coming up with that answer that
you're unaware of
that's right that's very good I I have
the one dream thing that Luke allowed me
to keep well you know he would have let
me keep whatever but the one thing that
I was like I want to keep is about a
dream and it sort of summarizes how I
feel about Christ and Buddha and Krishna
and everybody is that um I I still have
that dream where I'm in high school and
there's a test that day it's a horrible
dream I'm a senior
there's a math test and I haven't been
going to class like I know all this in
the dream I have memories in the dream
which is kind of drawing the Dockers and
a polar leopard skin
wrists bald slap exactly longer than the
trend lasted and I'm terrified and I
kind of scramble and I go around asking
people if I can borrow their notes I
really go through everything I'm like
can I cheat can I do summer school it's
panic
it's dread it's horrible it's a terrible
dream and then because I lose a dream
and occasionally sometimes this happens
even if you're not lucid you realize
it's a dream you go it's beautiful I
just go I'm almost 40 I'm a comedian
I don't need math I'm not even in school
anymore this is a dream there is no test
that to me is liberation having that
realization while you're in the dream
I'm in the dream and I realized that
there's that is that a recurring dream I
haven't had it in a while but yeah I've
had it at least 2530 times for sure and
it's worth having the panic to real to
wake up some I'm not waking up but in
the dream I'm becoming aware so I'm
waking up in that sense and I go there
is no dream and that there's no test and
that to me is what Christ was doing
that's good news good news is not you
die and you better swear your allegiance
to the right spelling of my name or I'm
gonna [ __ ] with you forever
you stupid [ __ ] that's not good news
good news is hey guess what no one's
going anywhere no one's doing anything
where could anything go it's all this as
I say on my mushroom trip it's all one
thing singing itself it's like a
fountain it's undulating it's working
out lawfully and your doubts and your
fears and your shame it's all welcomed
and it's all loved irrationally loved
but those dreams are like little gifts
to remind you of how far you've come
yeah you know they can be like little
gratitude bombs yeah if you just tweak
your perspective on them well I can in
naa there's a thing where you know a lot
of people myself included have like
relapse dreams oh wow most vivid that
with me do you
well most vivid where you're like I
can't I'm not gonna do it and then you
do it and then you're like okay it's on
and then you're like off to the races
using drinking whatever it is
many of these and they're terrifying
because they're so real and like
visceral and I've come to now look at
them as exactly what you just mentioned
like they're I you come you you you wake
up from them and you have this moment of
panic like oh my god I've just destroyed
my life or I blew it all right I have to
start over again you know I didn't
actually have that yeah beautiful now
and you can they can be terrifying but
they can also remind you of what it was
like and of all the work and the changes
that you've made to move away from that
regressive that's right maybe a little
test it ran a little test yeah and it
reminded you of where you are and how
far you've come so that was you with me
what sometimes do you are you still
doing that I became a when I first
became a vegan I used to I was more
precious about it and I would have more
oh no I just hated McDonald's dreams
right and now I'm I like to say I'm a
full-of-shit vegan or at fleek and
flexible meaning there's some meals that
I eat that are vegetarian but really
it's not about an overarching flag that
I fly nothing there's anything wrong
with that it's it's just become more I
don't know how to put it without
sounding really foolish yet let's just
say I'm 98% vegan right not not a
instant institutionalize it
well the Ramdas actually has a great
thing about this that I speaks to me was
he was a vegetarian which back in the
70s was as radical riding a vegan right
now and so he's a vegetarian his holy
people are vegetarians and the only
worse sandals made of leather but there
was a special company in India that made
them out of cows that died of natural
causes blah blah blah so he's very holy
about it but he caught himself whenever
he felt himself feeling superior to
other people and feeling as I sometimes
do like that he would go to KFC
Wow and he would mindfully eat some
disgusting and this is after they knew
how they abused those animals and
biological [ __ ] and he would eat it
and he'd say he hits it with the horror
of it and and I sometimes will
occasionally do something like that it's
usually with pizza so Mike
Keats are vegetarian but is the
motivation so that you can write size
your ego and not be so pious or is it
because some dust had a craving and
you're like couldn't help it I'm
sometimes foolish yet and sometimes I
will say that I have deliberately gone
because my wife is not vegan she's
vegetarian
pescetarian and I I'll catch myself just
like that sneaky little feeling I'm like
yeah I'm better than you and then what
I'll normally do in that moment is I'll
just have a bite of her feta or whatever
and just kind of write myself because
the toxicity of that feeling other times
though just to jump ahead it's because
I'm an ape you know that's interesting
because I think I think that that pious
Ness is a big problem in the vegan
community well I have a big thing about
this yeah go ahead yeah go ahead
no I mean I think I think you know the
vegan community does a pretty good job
of eating its own and attached to each
other because just like you know there's
always gonna be somebody who's more woke
yeah there's always gonna be somebody
who's more vegan and trying to hold you
know each other to some crazy standard
right and then attacking people for
falling short of that is doing nobody
any good
well there's yeah go ahead if there's
something that I want to embody or that
I enjoy embodying is the idea that if we
don't have to be so black-and-white
about it we're gonna be a little bit
Third Way which I understand I can feel
some vegan ears burning and being upset
and that's fine but a lot of vegans
listening right ah the idea though that
you're in or you're out isn't
necessarily helpful in introducing let's
say introducing somebody to how good it
feels
tea plans cuz I got into it for selfish
reasons it gets me high that's what I
tell people eating plants gets me high
like it just makes you feel better it's
me feel [ __ ] fantastic
so was it was it a like a so it wasn't a
spiritual impetus so I couldn't come
like later on to us I did that later
just like every [ __ ] veganize felt
better because it made me feel fantastic
and then later I was because I was no
longer eating animals
I was emboldened to watch some of the
videos like the carnism TED talk that I
was like oh [ __ ] I'm done I'll never do
it again but I wasn't brave enough to
watch those inside
stopped yeah exactly but the thing that
I think vegans can forget is that like
or lose touch with is that even though I
stopped eating meat when I was I don't
know 33 or something wasn't that meant I
ate meat for 33 years
yeah and as soon as I stopped like
smokers you know that gives you cancer
like as soon as they quit art
evangelizing and and like Christians as
that's the parallel that I want to get
to like there's a lot of parallels with
the institutionalization of religious
believes right and there's something
powerful in when Ramdas tells these
stories about being recognized in line
in a porno theater right
beautiful Rondo story I don't know this
story it's in it's deep one it's a deep
cut or me telling the story about being
horny in his guesthouse those are so
much more valuable than just like
stories of perfection so like we're
drawn to these people that still
understand that occasionally like you
got drunk and ate a Shake Shack burger
or whatever it might have been so I I
now enjoy let's not forget that even
though I stopped six seven years ago now
that I did for most of my life let's not
lose touch and compassion yeah for me
it's all us and at the end of crashing
your ear at Pink's I know right well
she's she's eating fries she actually
didn't see you take a bite out of a hot
dog heat in the show is not a vegan yeah
he was eating fried chicken at that
place in the south although I'm not I
don't eat it on camera but anyway so
losing touch with the with the part of
us that did eat meat and remaining
compassionate to that and also just
inviting people I think one of the
things that people don't want is to
belong to another club and to have
another thing so it's like now you're a
vegan and now you're on the record right
and you better not but some people want
to belong to a club they're looking for
a club to join that's fine and then I
believe this book speaks to that egos I
mean that's great doesn't it feel good
to be in put it on a flag and start a
parade but here's what the other thing
vegans are right and that's why they're
so annoying right but like what we do
with that rightness is on the record and
compassion is always important and
recognizing that people have
psychological
and also just unconscious
unconsciousness meaning they're not
thinking about it in the same way that
you are sometimes it is just a sandwich
with a friend and you coming in in your
woken us aggressive and hot isn't
necessarily the most loving or even the
most effective thing to do so I like to
demonstrate be a flee and be a flexible
vegan eat plants as much as you can
and don't fear the reaper of like whoops
I ate a Samoa because I bought some Girl
Scout cookies and I ate one all right
love yourself you're out of the club
love yourself love yourself mm-hmm
that's it yeah I think that's an
enlightened perspective on I agree I
used to think it was more than I mean
even if your if your agenda is to try if
you have that evangelizing in impulse
and you really do want to spread this
message it isn't effective nobody wants
to be told what they should or shouldn't
do or didn't especially need to feel bad
about the decisions that they're making
and you know we all live in glass houses
and taking other people's inventory is
just not a business I want to be in what
they put in their mouths which is very
personal and embarrassing and and I
don't know we live in a world where
there's so much death there's this great
quote where he says I forget who says it
forgive me it's some genius you like
Tolstoy it was whole story because as
long as we have slaughterhouses will
have battlefields and I was like oh
that's right on so we're living in this
unconscious state right and that's just
true was it an Einstein said something
similar like you can you can judge the
morality of a state by the way they
treat their animals yes or something
like that but look at the shining right
the movie The Shining we're in a hotel
and everything's fine but these the
history of the slaughtering of Native
Americans is like part of that story
it's America in a hotel and guess what
sometimes the elevator opens in a novel
entitled wave of blood comes out we're
all dealing with this suppression and
it's [ __ ] tricky so be careful how
you wake people out right you know what
I mean and be compassionate and remember
how you woke up and I'm gay I'm pretty
sure it wasn't because somebody came in
and made me feel shitty it might be
because somebody was like hey eating
plants gets you high I like that yeah
gets us that's moral or
yes it's joy its abundance look at the
[ __ ] [ __ ] they're just growing out of
the earth that you can eat in the
diversity and the color and the way that
it makes you feel and what it does
biochemically to your body
these are hints that's a metaphor eat
living things and feel life that's
beautiful eat dead things and feel death
get out of here so what do you what are
you struggling with right now like
what's the mountain you're trying to
climb what emotionally and spiritually
like what's the thing that's coming up
for you right now that you're that
you're doing battle with you just mean
in general no yeah not off of veganism
no no no not off just in general I would
imagine and I'm I'm sure I'm projecting
please but you know having this show on
HBO and suddenly being you know like you
were successful before but that put you
in a different you know kind of pecking
order in your career and I'm sure you
know if you walk down the street
wherever you go people know who you are
like does that did that [ __ ] with your
ego did you have you had to kind of
right-size yourself in that way that's
interesting she seems super grounded
about the whole thing well that's kind I
I liked Fame I like my level of Fame
it's weird I don't mind leaning into my
psychology and sort of giving my giant
the treats that I want I try not to be
too attached to them but it's fun to
play the game for example one of the
reasons I work so well with dad I
mentioned is because of the psychology I
have of my father so I can see a
dysfunction in myself
and instead of ignoring it I can
mobilize it I can go oh you like working
with big powerful people conan judd you
know what i mean
go for it you want to please daddy this
daddy I'll get you on HBO that sounds
weird but you know what I'm saying I
don't mean to culture daddy that's
sounded weird but this father figure or
my therapist I have a male therapist
that's me leaning into my dysfunction
going I like pleasing men you're a man
let me try and get you to love me and
we'll even talk about right that sounds
like a super healthy relationship with
your therapist they're trying to get him
to like you well I want him to
yeah that's part of it but we talk about
that and we work with that it's not
necessarily that I want him to like me
but I want to impress him with how good
at therapy I am and that makes me good
at therapy and that makes me more honest
and it makes me do the work you know I'm
saying so it is unhealthy
but I'm using it I Malcolm izing it into
being good at therapy which actually
helps me shed some of that boy I hope my
therapist likes me stuff but he likes me
because I'm good at there because I'll
come in and I'll tell them everything
it's that's that's the see most people
that would want to get their therapist
to like them would then just going in
lie no tell the therapist what they
think I'm playing yes this is advanced
no I'm gonna tell him every [ __ ] up
thing ever and he's gonna go [ __ ] one
session with Peters I'm with Dan and
that's that's the real [ __ ] I come to
score I'm here to score I want to be on
the board and that makes me a good
patient so that's using an unhealthy
thing for a healthy thing but what were
you talking about
just when you're failing with right now
so then like similarly what the type of
Fame that I have I heard Letterman say
that it turns the world into a small
town so I'm not Jake Gyllenhaal you know
but if I go to Whole Foods chances are
somebody listen to the podcast or
they'll have watched the show and
they'll just kind of be friendly you
know what I mean they'll be like yeah
hey I like your show my guy we went to
brunch yesterday I think I was like I
really liked your show and I get this
almost every day
I grew up evangelical or my wife left me
or I'm trying to do comedy like there's
millions of these people especially in
LA and we just talk and it's nice
there's God thanks man what's your name
hi nice to meet and I like that and so I
I don't struggle with that and I I also
don't it's happened enough that I don't
I don't really go like I'm a big fancy
boy I mean it just turns the world into
a small town wouldn't you like to live
in a small town I bet yeah yeah hey rich
that's what I live yeah I get this a lot
it's nice just like somebody looks at
you twice and they smile yeah you know
like huh okay
feed the beast the beast right so I one
of the ways I can keep my what my job is
sort of to like identify and solidify
and mobilize my eco so on one hand
that's very shallow right that's very
like it can be seen as depraved I'm in
the ego business the other thing is I'm
over here when I edit the show I go is
there one where Pete does this like
we're talking about him and see somebody
else that's how that's very elevated
that's an elevated game I'm like I don't
like the way Pete did this you know you
start to literally what around us is
your extricate yourself from your
identity mm-hmm so I have Pete show up
at 8 o'clock on a club and he shows up I
said that would crowd the last time I
didn't send up I was like which Pete do
you want do you want me to love
everything or you want me to be critical
like what do you want which game are we
gonna play
that's depersonalization in a healthy
way so when you're working with your ego
and you're and you're demonstrating and
putting it on display so much you can
actually have in my case a liberating
quality instead of going and that's me
you know I write guy who sells out
Madison Square Garden Bay when Val and I
are at home it's it and I'm not just
saying this to be like whoa what a what
a good thing it's like it's so ordinary
I spend four hours with the baby alone I
read her books I just read her I'll read
her Ryan's bug she's the baby she didn't
know that's that's the real life it's
it's so much just hanging out with Val
very boring very uneventful and then we
have these like flare-ups of what it is
that we do and then how has having a
baby changed how you kind of it's been
the best well when we talk about soul
consciousness it's very helpful for me
to have something that isn't yet selling
me who she is mm-hmm she doesn't yet
have a brain that's developed in that
way that's thinking in words and
insisting I am female I am white I am
born in LA I'm a los Angelino you know
what I mean and I like yellow rice not
white rice most people that you meet
this is a Ramdas thing or just you know
asking you if they're costume is on
straight like do I seem like a comedian
do you seem like a triathlete are we
doing it right are we vegans are we
vegans yeah you're reveal right now
probably go vegan and we just kind of go
around complimenting each other's
[ __ ] which is fine it's what we're
doing it's not- [ __ ] but my baby I
call her luminous emptiness she's
awareness she's light
but she's not she's empty yeah in the
beautiful way dense is a mountain but
spacious is this guy Dan that's what
they said about Maharaja these people
they're just like empty in the good way
so I thought my baby would be a
deterrent possibly you have a flare-up
where you're like this is gonna impede
my enlightenment then you're hanging out
with something that is enlightenment
that is Christ that is Christ with no
shoddy theology that's that's the Christ
yeah and it's [ __ ] amazing and I want
to hold her on my skin and be quiet with
her and she picks up on it man it's a
great great subtle game that's awesome
to play with a baby to see how how how
can you come to her level you know what
I mean right not I hate when I see
[ __ ] babies and Red Sox onesies you
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah and you know what
compassion sure fine but that's not
that's just a very that's a that's a
very you know easily identifiable way in
which a parent would program a child but
we all are doing that I hear that and I
have to be careful not to take my child
into a new agey well that's why we named
her Lila Jane uh Lila means the dancer
play of the universe it's a Hindu word
Jane is in case she doesn't like that
[ __ ] Jane is a cool girl she's a
photographer she smokes
menthols you know what I mean she wears
a beret she's cool or if she's sporty
she can be LJ right but then you have
this mental construct like okay these
are these two identities that three at
least are three that on some level
conscious or unconscious right you're
trying to instill in this person and I
can almost guarantee you that Leela will
be none of those getting's yeah yeah no
I know
I'm only here to be called on my
[ __ ] that would be nice and we talk
about all the time she'll probably be an
athlete she'll probably be a rational
thinker she'll love math and reason of
course you will but I'm also gonna be
very careful not and I like saying this
on the record even though it's it's got
some hooks but to it to assume that I
know how I'm gonna raise my daughter
because it's different every day but I
want I'm here to help that's something I
say to her I say you're welcome I say
you're welcome here
glad you're here it's just a good energy
and I also just say I'm here to help
I think about those like anime
characters there's always like second
anime truck there's like a big robot I'm
like a little child right that's me what
do you want you want me to break that
building and what do you want to be you
want to be an atheist are you [ __ ]
kidding me I'm like Penn Jillette is a
friend of mine wouldn't change him for
the world you know what I'm saying
irrational love what do you want to do
because I believe in you can look at him
mystically or not psychologically
there's there's a karma there's
something programmed in her and she's a
lawful unfolding of what's going on here
the fountain that's undulating and
recycling itself and playing with itself
so she's that part of it and I'm here to
help and am I open to the idea that
she'll surprise me and she'll be like a
hard materialist great you tell me my
mom comes to my house and knocks over my
Buddhas you understand I have something
I have a machine to rage against I have
an openness I have to counteract a
closeness with a vastness and that's my
Play no it'll be good I'll be
interesting to see how it plays out over
time and what she develops into but I'm
not afraid to be open about it yeah
because this is what it is like today
you know what I'm saying I might look
back and be like oh boy I was a fool I
sort of hope I do but I'm not afraid to
to speak of how I'd like it to be well
any resistance that you throw up is only
fomenting that which you are you know
railing against right yeah so to be
completely open and accepting and
supportive is really the only choice we
just want to love her irrationally
that's all that's what I say to Val
that's how I love my wife it's not like
this is a new thing you have an amazing
relationship with her oh yeah I
completely agree yeah I'm like I can't
believe that that the universe put
something in my favorite package that
happened to be exactly what I needed and
what I what I also what I wanted and
that she's on this journey with me it's
[ __ ] incredible
I love it well one of the things that we
you know our lives and our stories are
very different but we both had mishaps
in a first marriage and I've heard you
talk about
kind of you know owning your part in
what went wrong in that being you know
wrapped up in your in your own career
and like not seeing her and just sort of
you know she was there to support your
vision and your dream but then
leveraging that experience to be able to
be a fully formed person that could be
in the kind of relationship that you're
in right right I had to be broken yeah
it's a three brush himself into the
person we had be with Val and so how do
you so what is the you know there's a
secret to it but like what are some of
the guiding principles that keep you
guys healthy well I say there all the
time I just want good for you that's an
important one it we're not swingers
we're not open but there's almost like a
psychological openness that I have for
her which means that I just want good
for her it's it's kind of hard to say
it's it's just the way that I'm I go
against my possessiveness we have our
boundaries and we are just us you know
what I'm saying but it's almost like my
love for her so radical that there's
nothing I try to I try to experiment and
play in that space of like there's
nothing you could do I'm your best
friend
you [ __ ] Jude Law details you don't even
that's it Mike Birbiglia job details but
like I'm on her side that's what we say
all the time it's just a lot of language
I say it's very routine to just say
you're my favorite person I love being
with you I love holding your hand I love
your body my wife this is self-serving
which she's never taken her clothes off
in front of me without me telling her
some noise or some look on my face that
makes her feel Valley I'm gonna cry
it's just it's just love it's just like
a lot of deliberate mmm work and
language we happen to have the same love
languages like I love to you know she
hates folding laundry so this morning I
folded the laundry and was just like you
leave it on the couch she's like you
fold the laundry and really I knew it
would make you feel that like real
little things not making someone guess
just like again she does that for me
Const
and saying like I love telling her
you're 30% funnier than me and that's
something I said her all the time
I'll say a joke and then she says that
30% funnier and I'm like you're so
talented I say you're a true talent just
speak to her wounds and she speaks to
mine I'm gonna get emotional but you
know you know somebody that's well you
see where they are and you remind them
when they're getting off the path so a
lot of it had to do with the early
stages of making sure you were with the
right person before that you were safe
and able to open up this much yeah so
that time in my life was you know
important now that we're in we can just
sort of open all the blinds yeah well
there's a level of honesty like it like
the acceptance of each other
at least from my arms-length perspective
just seems to be unquestioned like you
can be completely honest with this
person and know that you're accepted
right right I love it
then that's what I'm talking about in
the book is loving yourself that way and
the work that I do on myself is for Val
like all the books I read some of them
are on the table are about consciousness
right for the most part and sometimes
people are like do you read baby books
and I'm like every book I read is a baby
book and every book I read is a
relationship book and every book I read
is a book about work and every book I
read is a book about art it's all one
thing
so like the work that I do a gret well I
go to therapy for Val and for me getting
ahead of stuff like the the levels of
honesty I make sure they're not creepy
like there's almost like a smarmy like
yeah I don't know what I'm trying to
articulate but there's there's a level
of oversharing but it's really about you
being like I'm sorry I pooped on the
lawn like some things I keep from her
just cuz I want to be attractive
together and like a solid or a person
for her but like although it's it's
about the motivation behind the share
exactly if it's helpful to me in the
morning like Val threw move at me two
nights ago and I wasn't in the mood and
in the morning I just was like I'm
really sorry I wasn't horny last night
and just being able to say that like I
just want that that works for me but
you're supposed to be the guys for Niall
I know and and I talked about this on
the stage like on the stage on stage Val
is that sort of energy that works for me
sexually as well like we talk about it
as if it's somebody else
we gotta have you notice that I I can't
really perform sexually unless it's my
idea like I just need to be able to say
that I go like it sucks that my body is
such a coward that I need to be like
this is my werewolf idea cuz that's sexy
to him but I wish it wasn't that way but
we just have to deal with it D
personally and I can and and a big thing
as I go that may be how it is and I can
work on it you know what I mean like I
hate resigning to things or shortcomings
and just going those are the ABCs of me
babe right I don't do that I ain't when
people do that when they just go sorry
I'm not a good listener work on it
[ __ ] you know you mean like if I can
figure that [ __ ] out cuz you're not dead
yet
you still have yeah agency and freedom
but I think people need they need
they're crashing in order to face that
kind of stuff like it takes it's a lot
harder to voluntarily sign up for that
kind of work yeah my sure in some kind
of crisis right where your hand is being
held in the flame or you're losing
something that might be why the
cancellation seems like such a
liberating feeling for me interesting
because I'm getting old enough and I've
done it enough times to realize that
this is where the juice is the real Oh
where's the growth opportunity what's
next yeah and trusting and believing and
knowing that there's something around
the corner that is fit for you that's
right this is what that time is about
that's right you have a lot more time to
go and promote your book buddy I know
how it is I worked on this for three
yeah and this the torte the press
schedule when I was gonna be shooting
the fourth season was two days two days
we were gonna carve out while I was
shooting and I told my editor I was like
the states that I'm talking about in
this book are not easy we're talking
about how hard it is to be present and
to be in her awareness or whatever you
want to say and when I'm shooting my
show it was very hard to stay in that
place I wasn't feeling it sometimes I'll
just tell people that I'm like yeah
sometimes when I'm in that place I feel
this
not in that place right now you know
Devine right like I can't we're not all
one right now I'm stuck and and that's
what I wish pastors could do I don't
believe it today sorry I just saw a
video about an earthquake in India I'm
sorry I don't feel it so sometimes I
feel that but it's very helpful to me
when I can spend my mornings with Lila
reading and being quiet and seeing the
Sun coming through our weird old windows
and the glass sort of distorts the light
and see that and see the trees and all
that same kind Drive here to see your
beautiful house and see the nature and
have it speak to me I can get in touch
with the state that I was in as I was
writing this book in the mornings and
then I can more effectively go out and
communicate that as opposed to like a
haggard
stressed TV guy right right who's
wearing nine hats and then one of them
has to be like I also wrote a book I
didn't want this to be I also wrote a
book I've been three years of my life
and it's like very
you should be proud and you should go
everywhere yes
if I would have been on the writers room
today I would not be on the podcast you
see yeah and now you can do lots of
podcasts and do lots of podcast and by
the way I'm sorry tour who got I'm the
bestseller list just from doing podcast
before the book came out yeah that's the
way it is these days that's right
and I sorry to be so bald that's what we
say in writers rooms it's so obvious but
I mean like yeah I wanted to come on to
get the word out about the book because
the book matters to me
well there's you should be completely
unapologetic about that but there's also
I wrote the book this this is gonna
sound may be cheesy there were two R's
to relieve interest or relieve suffering
there's a lot of people that are
suffering mm-hmm but maybe their wives
left them maybe they lost their faith
they might be having some sort of pain
that I also experienced so I wrote the
book to talk about and walk people
through how I relieve my own suffering
and then restore restore a connection to
the mystery let's not say God because
it's loaded but some sort of
participation with that's playful and
fun and spacious with the fundamental
what is this that we're all sharing that
we're all stuck in this conundrum then
we can analyze and we can dissect and
build up and break down build bridges
and rockets and understand a lot like
I talk about science being like sheet
music you know what I mean it's like we
can break it down it's [ __ ] beautiful
I'm not putting down science but we're
sort of still sort of stuck going like
the thing that's breaking it down is
also a part of the thing yeah you know
what I mean so it's like it's just as
weird it's like Mario realizing
everything's made of pixels like good
for you Mario your main effect sounds
like what did this like what is the
Japanese man that made this so it's
really really fun to restore and the
connection methods that I described in
this book are as liberal as they get
there's no Dogma and there's no group to
join at the end of this book in fact I
almost called the book gateway God
because it's the idea that every concept
of God that you have is that it's a
gateway god it's the book it's the
bookmark for now mm-hmm
and you can close the book you can put
it aside forever you don't have to go
back you can come back you can move
forward you can move backwards it's just
there's an Alan Watts quote I wonder if
I can find it when a chicken comes out
of the eggshell the Zen philosopher Alan
Watts said the eggshell is not something
to be deplored it's certainly something
to be broken but have the shell not
existed the chicken wouldn't have been
protected so in precisely the same way
images religious ideas religious symbols
exist in order to be constructively and
lovingly broken that's it mmm
constructing constructively broken and
lovingly broken right so in other words
we welcome you stress testing our ideas
around faith that's odd that's right
yeah and and losing your faith to find
it is I use I thought it was the worst
thing that could happen and now I'm like
that you have how you get there how do
you have conviction about your faith
unless you've unless you've lost it or
it's been so jesus west desert it's in
the book it's in the story Jesus going
into the desert for 30 days in Buddha
going into the woods for 30 days hey
that's peculiar but I'm just saying it's
built into these stories it's staring
you in the face you weren't supposed to
be wearing a Red Sox jersey or a Jesus
onesie as a baby you were supposed to
[ __ ] give it resist it break it
rediscover it rebuild it and talk about
it because we're all stuck in this and
we need help you know what I mean yeah
and it's and it doesn't help anybody to
be a perfect vegan
or a perfect Christian or / it doesn't
nobody my dick is so soft even thinking
we're not anyway that's right so get out
of here
alright have your parents read this book
you know I want to talk to you about
that Bianca Lane Mulaney gave me a blurb
and he was like I'm so glad I'm not
related to Pete he pulls no punches and
when I read it I thought I was gentle
with them and I'm curious what you
thought I gave well your your sense of
of gentility can only be measured
against your your assessment of the
truth right so I have no comparison to
measure it against but I felt like you
know you didn't pull punches I didn't
feel like you were being untoward ly you
know cruel or anything like that you're
being very honest yeah but there's
aspects of that honesty that I would
imagine you know depending upon the
sensitivity of your parents that would
might be challenging for them to digest
right I gave it to my mom and my brother
I didn't give it to my dad mm-hmm but it
was because my mom and my brother I
thought would what I wanted them to do
was make sure that what I was writing
was how they remembered it and my father
who I love very much wasn't necessarily
the best witness of what happened not
just because he drank but because he I
don't know I don't think his mind really
works that way and he wasn't around as
much so what I was writing was what it
was like living in the house in the
tension of kind of a strange
relationship with my dad what especially
when we were young
something happened around 30 I think my
mom gave up and she stopped trying to
change my dad and that sort of made a
more benign strangeness yeah well when I
was young I wanted to share the story of
why I became a comedian and and I'm a
believer that nobody really becomes a
comedian without some sort of turmoil or
something and mine was that my parents
fought every night and that's very
valuable to me to share more explicitly
than I have on my podcast what it was
like living in a house where we just had
like a nightly screaming ritual and I
thought that was normal
mm-hmm I just thought it was normal like
it was like a play that we did like my
dad would come home and they'd fight and
would go upstairs it wasn't physical but
it sort of make the point that it didn't
need to be physical that we were
children and we felt unsafe and I said I
think I liken them to Greek gods
throwing one Thunderbolt and that me and
my brother were like dogs waiting for
the fireworks to stop and that's very
sad I can't read that part of the book
without kind of tearing up and I made
sure that my brother remembered it the
same way and my mother remembered it the
same way and I love my dad and I've made
peace with my dad and it was important
to me that he didn't come off like a
villain or something but the truth is he
and my mom don't get along their
personalities don't get along I sort of
say there my dad was like a dog and my
mom was like a finicky cat and like dogs
and cats they fought and that sort of
baked in me my need to be a peacekeeper
and that baked in me my need to be a
good boy and my good boy going into the
church was the best way to be a good boy
and also a church nobody was arguing or
fighting or mean or yelling so like and
by the way my dad was never mean to me
they just didn't get along they and when
it was pre therapy and pre emotional
availability so there was no there was
no like hey sorry about last night you
know on the way to school my dad
wouldn't be like that must have been
really hard for you guys I'm so sorry
there was none of that and that's when
you go you know what I'm gonna go up on
stage and make strangers love me so what
did your not what did you wrong what was
your mom's reaction she said you were
too easy on us mmm that's what she said
I was ready for her to like fact-check
it and she had a couple thoughts about
the timeline and she was right I jump
around on the timeline in a way that and
in not important ways that only she
would notice like where my bald spot was
whether that was junior high or high
school that's sort of blurry in the book
but I didn't think that was important
yeah but she said you were easy on us
and honestly when you're writing a book
like this I there's there is a version
you could have written that was a that
could have been harder but I didn't
that's not the book I just wanted to be
like this is what it felt like growing
up and this is why I ran to church where
it was safe
and honestly I hope the book sounds
affectionate because church was that
place for me even though they told me
that you know my dick was the devil and
they didn't even tell me that directly
they just were indirect enough that
allowed me to sort of have that
perversion of thought I don't mean
sexual perversion I just mean like I
filled in the blanks in an unhealthy way
and some of that was supported by some
of the church volunteers and stuff but
there was an affection for the church it
was a safe place it's the first place I
tried stand-up it's the first place I
felt funny and not the first place I
felt funny but I felt safe enough to go
up on stage and do stand-up Corral and
yeah they would they had to let you know
love their neighbor and that was great
and and it gave me grown-up especially
male grown-ups they were interested in
what is this not not just like the
stories of what's happening in our lives
what they wanted to talk about things
that just seemed so feminine to me like
where everything came from and how we're
supposed to behave and feelings and
thoughts and dreams and all that stuff
so the church was that's what I'm saying
with the gay way god thing it wasn't
right or wrong or good or bad or in or
out it was just it's just the third
grade and then you move maybe you moved
to the second grade maybe then you moved
to the fifth grade then you're in
college then you're in community cause
it just doesn't matter you're moving
around and that's that's all in the game
mmm so what is the main thing that you
want people to take away from the book
that it basically started to repeat
myself that it is all we do right that
that losing your faith is actually a
really important thing I could read this
part from the book too because I just
saw it it's it's kind of breaking down
the hero's journey foot in my own in my
own words you're in the village and
that's nice safe familiar comfortable
that was me in church basically it's
chicken night and you love chicken but
you feel the call to go to the woods
you've been told your entire life not to
go in the woods but you're compelled and
you leave on chicken night and it's not
nice it's unsafe unfamiliar
uncomfortable and you're cold and hungry
and lost but you get strong and you kill
your own chickens and learn your own way
you meet others people who've never even
heard of your village
and you learn you slay dragons get
wounds find swords and heal you find out
what you're made of and realize what
you're looking for was part of you all
along but the story doesn't end there
the final step in every hero's journey
is to come back you return to the
village the same but different and the
village is the same but you see it
differently and you tell everyone what
you've learned in those forbidden woods
around the fire adding spices to their
chicken they've never dreamed of telling
the story of the time you did the one
thing you were told never to do now God
isn't something I believe in it's
something I feel all of us soaking in so
that's it yeah I get emotional this is
data I'm 40 I'm almost 40 I only want to
talk about the real [ __ ] you know what I
mean and that's not to say that comedy
and silliness isn't a part of my life I
love being silly for silly sake but
there's I just it was like written on my
in my bone marrow to like tell this
story and that's why I'm excited to come
on this show and promote it and and get
the word out well
beautifully done my friend thank you
I'm excited to see you birth this thing
into the world thank you very have all
this bandwidth to go out and tidy him
about it Montana sky so thank you yeah
and great thank you um really appreciate
it come back and talk to me again
sometime
I'd love to if only to see this property
yeah all right so we're I'm gonna take
psychedelics you said I down down in the
tepee unsupervised good deal man
yeah all right look at it it's being
awesome a Pete Holmes
yes I do be sex comedy sex God available
wherever you buy fine books you can
order it now that would be nice
pre-order it now that's what your free
order yeah pre-order it now it comes out
May would may write a 1400 Sam man thank
you Congrats thank you best of luck my
pleasure peace plants
[Music]